[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat je vous propose ce
matin de continuer à suivre le travail
de la commission d' enquête du sénat sur
la gestion de la crise du coronavirus
les sénateurs ont entendu la directrice
du centre européen de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies
l'occasion de faire le bilan de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire en europe
alors que l'organisation mondiale de la
santé craint une hausse des décès en
europe en octobre et en novembre
je vous laisse écouter cette audition et
merci de me donner cette occasion de
m'exprimer devant vous nous vous avons
déjà envoyé nos réponses aux questions
que vous nous avez selon le centre
européen pour la prévention et le
contrôle des maladies le cdc a été créé
en 2005 suite à une autre épidémie celle
du sart ce en 2003 la tâche la démission
de ce centre est d'identifier évaluer et
communiqué les risques concernant la
santé humaine posée par des maladies
infectieuses existantes ou émergentes
donc il s'agit d' évaluation des risques
et de maladies infectieuses donc nous ne
pouvons pas tout le champ de la santé
publique et pour ce qui est de la
prévention du contrôle des des maladies
et bien cela reste 2e la composent des
états membres paient donc nous basons
sur les données factuelles les preuves
scientifiques disponibles et nous
permettons ainsi aux états membres
d'apporter leur propre
réponse mais c'est à eux de décider en
pleine autorité s'ils vont utiliser nos
recommandations au nom et il y a tout un
spectre
si vous voulez il ya certains états
membres qui vont suivre exactement nos
propositions et d'autres qui vont et
bien choisis parmi les options
c'est ainsi que cela s'est passé et pas
seulement pour la copie 19 mai de tout
temps donc il s'agit de surveillance
l'ex il ya deux piliers si vous voulez
l'ins et la notification par les états
membres à des maladies qu'ils ont pu
observer dans leur pays par le biais
d'une législation spécifique qui permet
ce signalement donc ce signalement c'est
une des parties parfois il ya un certain
retard et l'autre partie c'est une sorte
de veille épidémiologique
donc il s'agit et bien d'un suivi d'un
monitoring nous cherchons donc y compris
sur les réseaux sociaux les rumeurs 2
maladie tout événement inhabituel
donc nous effectuons cette veille
essayons de déterminer quelles mesures
doivent être prises et une autre partie
de nos attributions et bien consiste à
assister les états membres pour leur
prêt pour leur permettre d'être prêt par
le biais d'exercices de simulation que
nous menons avec des avec les pays
membres
nous avons des outils de qui nous
permettent de classer de hiérarchiser
les risques et il y a également et bien
les comptes-rendus le reporting que les
états membres doivent effectuer quand il
ya des menaces à la santé publique qui
sont transfrontalières donc nous
effectuons une analyse et nous avons un
système de réponse et d' avertissement
précoce qui permet est bien de mettre en
relation les états membres entre eux
leur permettre de partager des
informations concernant certains
événements les mesures qu'ils ont prises
ou qu'il s'apprête à prendre et c'est
bien sûr comme une situation dans une
situation comme la nôtre actuellement
cela est précieux nous avons également
et bien une action sur le renforcement
des capacités pour ce qui est de la
surveillance des épidémies et
notre stade de préparation pour pouvoir
apporter une réponse et enfin et ce
n'est pas des moindres la communication
nos efforts de communication
une grande part de notre travail
consiste à évaluer et procéder à une
évaluation des risques rapide donc
essayer d'identifier les risques qui
paraissent donc être apparue non
seulement dans les états membres
donc en europe mais aussi en dehors de
l'europe et qui pourrait bien avoir des
implications pour les citoyens européens
dont cela fait partie de notre
évaluation des risques et la ono
identifions un risque qu'une maladie
soit importé en europe où par exemple
que ce soit parce que des personnes
voyagent en provenance de ces pays
infectés au toucher en europe ou dans
l'autre sens donc ça c'est ce que nous
faisons
de tout temps le coroner virus est bien
où nous avons fait tout cela c'est à
dire que nous avons d'abord et bien
essayé de d'apprendre sur ces foyers
infectieux ces clusters de pneumonie est
donc en décembre 2019 puis en janvier
l'agent donc infectieux a été identifié
comme étant le nouveau coronavirus et
nous avons donc évaluer les risques à
plusieurs reprises nous avons désormais
onze mises à jour de cette évaluation
des risques parce que au début bien sûr
nous disposions de peu de connaissances
et à chaque fois que des preuves des
données étaient disponibles et bien nous
avons procédé à une actualisation de
notre évaluation des risques nous avons
également donné des orientations des
recommandations aux états membres sur
les différentes options qui se
présentent et à
en terme donc de gestion des risques et
de préparation des du secteur de la
santé et ce non seulement dans les
établissements de santé mais également
dans les maisons de retraite et en eau
début début janvier le nous avions les
premiers cas en europe nous avons mis en
place un système de protocoles de
surveillance
nous avons également conseillé les états
membres en termes de tests et de
recherche des cas contacts à contacter
racing est également des conseils des
recommandations sur la manière dont les
professionnels de santé en particulier
ceux qui étaient en première ligne
pouvait gérer cette crise sanitaire
alors bien sûr au cours des huit
derniers mois cela constamment évolué
nous avons également
fournit des conseils sur les voyages les
écoles les centres de réfugiés tous ces
différents singles cadre environnement
où le coronavirus a bien su eu un impact
majeur à l'heure actuelle nous préparons
essentiellement avec nos collègues des
états membres comment de préparer à la
saison hivernale aux faits notamment
qu'il n'y aura pas seulement le grenat
virus il mais est bien la grippe
saisonnière et d'autres virus saisonnier
tout cela je simultanément donc qu'est
ce qui doit être mis en place en termes
de tests en termes de surveillance
épidémiologique pour être sûr de pouvoir
et bien effectuer un suivi de tous ces
virus en même temps si vous le souhaitez
je peux également vous donner un
panorama de la situation en europe
actuellement sinon je m'arrête ici
écoutez c'est peut-être effectivement
intéressant données en quelques minutes
le panorama de la situation en europe
merci ok très bien et bien il y a eu un
pic en avril
et avec toutes les mesures prises par
les différents états membres
ça c'est suivi d'un déclin de 80% d'eau
que nous étions arrivés à 20% des cas
que nous avions au 9 avril et depuis six
ou sept semaines nous voyons à nouveau
une augmentation des cas dans la plupart
des pays
nous notons cette résurgence mais dans
la plupart des pays
ce n'est pas le cas uniformément dans
tout le pays
dans la plupart des pays il ya suivant
les zones des situations épidémiques
différente avec une circulation active
du virus et des transmissions plus forte
dans certaines zones au sein d'un même
pays
ce que nous voyons également aujourd'hui
c'est que les plus jeunes des gens plus
jeunes sont affectés nous avons vu que
les taux d'hospitalisation sont plus bas
lorsque ces personnes plus jeunes et
bien eux développent des symptômes et
des formes moins sévère de la maladie
donc ceci constitue un un vraiment un
changement par rapport à ce que nous
avions observé en mars avril dans
quelques pays
on nous voyons cette résurgence il y a
pour certains d'entre eux des personnes
plus âgées qui sont également affectées
ce qui induit des taux d'hospitalisation
plus important donc on entrevoir bien
des mesures plus régionaliser dont nous
ne
voyons pas encore les fruits mais mon
attente et mon espoir c'est que dans ces
pays qui ont maintenant a pris de
l'expérience de la situation de mars et
avril pourront réagir plus tôt
de manière à ce que cela ne tienne pas
les taux qu'on a eu en mars avril
merci merci madame pour cette
présentation rapide mais très
intéressante
je passe la parole aux rapporteurs
catherine des roches ses propos
liminaires
ça fait une première question qui
tiennent sur les harmonisation entre les
différents pays est ce qu'au moment de
l'expérience italienne
vous avez donné des consignes
particulières aux autres pays européens
de façon à tirer les leçons de ce qui se
passait en italie est-ce que de son côté
la france vous a alerté sur les
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
équipements de protection et est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas dû justement plutôt à
voir au niveau européen une commande
globale pour éviter toutes les tensions
que l'on a eues en matière de le marasme
aussi de test ou de réactifs ça c'est ma
première question
la deuxième c'est vous dites que vous
donnez des conseils un peu à l'ensemble
des pays
comment vous expliquez des discours très
différents d'un pays à l'autre des
agences nationales sanitaire qui en
effet non pas du tout les mêmes
communication d'un pays à l'autre et
comment on peut concilier un discours
commun même si on sait qu'on est sur des
politiques de santé des états membres
qui sont du fait de leurs propres
compétences
et puis le deuxième point est plus axé
sur la recherche
comment vous expliquer l'échec relatif
de 2
de l'essai discovery a été lancée par la
france avec l'inserm et cannes qui n'a
rien fédérer au delà de nos frontières
dont que l'explication selon vous à cela
et puis est-ce qu'il ya eu dans d'autres
pays des controverses entre les experts
scientifiques comme nous les connaissons
en france
merci je vous passe la parole
amon merci beaucoup pour ces questions
et bien en ce qui concerne
l'harmonisation en février nous avons
proposé aux pays différents scénarii
dans lesquelles nous avons décrit ce qui
le type de mesures qui devaient être
prises dans tel ou tel scénario et il a
fallu un petit peu de temps pour que les
pays aient bien identifier quel scénario
dans quel scénario et se trouvait il ya
par exemple un scénario vous avez des
foyers infectieux locaux et d'autres où
vous avez une transmission beaucoup plus
globale et donc le développement
semblait
aller plus dans le sens d'une
transmission plus généralisée et on ne
pouvait pas déterminer véritablement
d'où était partie la chaîne de
transmission est dans cette situation
nous avons dit très clairement qu'il
fallait bien sûr tester les personnes
contactent isoler les cas recéder à des
quarantaines pour ces personnes
contactent pour ce qui est de la
distanciation physique qui devait être
maintenue
cela a mené au bout du compte à ce que
les pays aient bien ferme les commerces
et je crois que la première chose que la
plupart des pays ont décidé l'été est
bien d'interdire les grands
rassemblements que ce soit des fêtes
foraines des rassemblements sportifs est
peu à peu en français dans le texte
eh bien ces mesures ont été prises donc
commerces fermés bon beaucoup de pays
ont décidé deux effets de la fermeture
des écoles et on en est venu à la
situation où on est bien
la population ne pouvait sortir
uniquement pour acheter les faire
procéder aux achats de première
nécessité donc il ya eu une évaluation
locale
et comme ces de l'autorité et de la
responsabilité des états membres
eh bien parfois même si l'état membre
dans cet état membre
il se peut que ce ne soit pas à
l'échelon national mais à l'échelon
local régional ou de la province que ses
décisions étaient prises pour ce qui est
de l'équipement de protection
eh bien il était possible effectivement
de procéder à cet achat pour y louer la
commission européenne pouvait
effectivement procédé à cet achat mais
il fallait que les états membres et bien
se manifeste et indique la quantité
qu'ils dont ils avaient besoin une fois
que ce contrat était que plus ils
pouvaient recevoir ces produits seul a
été mis en oeuvre et nous avons eu des
indications de certains pays
concernant est bien certain réactif ou
certains consommables pour les tests
également pour des cartes syndromes
grippaux en janvier nous avons demandé
aux pays est ce que vous avez vous
observé une pénurie de ces produits
nécessaires aux tests et ces pays et
bien n'avait pas pu anticiper qu'il
qu'il y aurait pénurie parce que bien
l'augmentation des cas a été si rapide
donc je crois que c'est là un des
enseignements que nous avons pu tirer il
est préférable d'avoir un stock
important de ce type de produit
également de médicaments essentiels il
est par exemple et bien une pénurie de
certains médicaments pour les services
de réanimation
de soins intensifs pas généraliser mais
certains médicaments
[Musique]
donc il ya une pénurie d'eau de ces
médicaments et conseille les conseils
que nous avons données étaient les mêmes
pour tous les pays mais comme je les
mentionnaient dans mon propos
introductif les pays
ils peuvent choisir de retenir ce qui
leur semble pertinent par rapport à leur
situation spécifique
et comme ces situation était différente
en mars parce que certains pays comme
l'italie
dans certains dans certaines régions de
l'italie avait une augmentation très
importante alors que d'autres régions de
l'italie et d'autres régions en europe
ne voyait que des cas sporadiques dont
lille et situation différait est donc
bien sûr les réactions ont été
différentes
et en termes d décalage entre les
conseils et ce qui a été retenu est mis
en oeuvre
bien je crois qu'il n'y a là rien de
spécifique à la france est rien et même
spécifique aux coronavirus ça fait 25
ans que je travaille dans le domaine des
maladies infectieuses et j'ai vécu
plusieurs de ces crises et je peux vous
dire que ça survient à chaque fois merci
vous n'avez pas répondu sur la recherche
discovery ni sur la controverse
scientifique
je n'ai pas tout je crains de ne pas
avoir tout à fait compris ce que madame
des roches avait en tête ce à quoi il
faisait référence est ce que vous
pourriez je lui passe la parole oui dans
le cadre des légumes unique la france a
lancé avec l'inserm
un essai clinique on appelle discovery
et qui a été qu'ils étaient ouverts à
plusieurs pays or les
a sion qui sont rentrés dans les essais
sont exclusivement français avec
quelques axes passion luxembourgeois je
crois qu'ils se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main
et comment vous expliquer je sais pas si
vous avez une connaissance des
différents essais pratiqués discovery
recouvrit donc ma question était celle
ci en effet pourquoi cet échec de
d'ouverture de laisser or en france
et puis les controverses nous avons
actuellement beaucoup de controverses
scientifiques la fois sur le port du
masque aussi sur le médicament sur l'idh
roxy chloroquine beaucoup de de
controverses scientifiques qui
déstabilise un peu le la population et
est ce que d'autres pays sont aussi dans
cette situation et puis je reviens quand
même sur la première question parce que
moi ce que j'aimerais savoir mais vous
pouvez nous le donne et ultérieurement
dans le cadre d'une contribution écrite
c'est eux les conseils que vous donner
les réponses que vous avez des pays
essentiellement la france
à quel moment la france est-ce que dès
le départ la france voisine en chine où
tout va bien on a besoin de rien à quel
moment ils ont dit qu'ils avaient besoin
de quelque chose c'est ça qui nous
intéresse enfin qui intéresse la
commission non madame x
merci madame amon avis merci beaucoup
[Musique]
oui je crois que j'ai compris maintenant
et bien laissé discovery était l'un des
essais cliniques qui a été mis en place
et au haut débit mme illi à une sorte de
feuille de concurrence entre ces
différents essais cliniques et les faits
en a été que la plupart de ces essais se
sont révélés trop petit à trop faible
ampleur pour avoir des résultats
probants alors ce qui est des essais
cliniques ne fait pas partie de nos
attributions il s'agit plutôt de les
attributions de l' agence européenne des
médicaments ou d'agents ce médical mais
ce que nous avons dit c'est que des
médicaments des thérapies préexistantes
pouvait être testés donc avec tous les
contrôles nécessaires il fallait qu'il y
ait une cohorte de patients suffisamment
important pour que cela puisse faire
l'objet d'une interprétation est au
début et bien il semble que il a semblé
qu'il était plus pertinent d'avoir
quelque chose de multinationales plutôt
que d'avoir bien dépendre que de deux
parties ce que de participants ou à sept
participants fait donc on a voulu avoir
des participants de de différentes
nationalités mais on a eu des cours trop
peu importante alors pour l'hydro xi
chloroquine
eh bien il semble que c'est un
traitement utile et qui aident
véritablement les patients dans pour
certaines pathologies et mais ce que les
essais cliniques nous ont montré c'est
que ça n'avait pas d'effet véritablement
mis en évidence pour le coronavirus donc
c'est bien
vous savez c'est un exemple assez
typique de ce qui peut paraître
prometteur de prime abord et ce qui ne
s'avère pas et bien véritablement
probants et les les pratiques établies
de procéder à des essais cliniques
contrôlés en double aveugle randomisée
tout tous et toutes ces réglementations
tout c'est pas lucratif qui permettent
de et bien comparer différents
traitements c'est ça qui permet vrai
véritablement d'évaluer la l'efficacité
et l'innocuité d'une thérapie j'espère
avoir répondu à votre question
sylvie vermeillet merci monsieur le
président madame la directrice vous avez
déclaré à plusieurs médias que l'europe
devait se préparer à une deuxième vague
mais qu'elle ne serait pas
nécessairement désastreuses
qu'est ce que ça veut dire désastreuses
pour vous est-ce que
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on peut
imaginer se re confiné ou pas est-ce
qu'on peut éviter un confinement
j'aimerais savoir également à combien
vous estimez le taux d'immunité de la
population en europe à ce jour après
l'été et est ce que vous estimez
finalement à la lumière de vos exposé
que nos hôpitaux en europe sont très du
coup pour faire face à une deuxième
vague est ce que vous estimez que nous
avons les stocks de médicaments
nécessaires en europe aujourd'hui
merci merci madame amon
oui merci
eh bien on m'a posé cette question de la
seconde vague à nos trois reprises la
notion de deuxième vague nous vient de
la grippe a mean mean you mais avec de
nouveaux pathogènes
on observe souvent qu'il y à un premier
pic puis un déclin et quelques temps
après une résurgence il y à un débat est
ce que nous voyons est ce que une
résurgence limitée ou est-ce
véritablement le début d'une deuxième
vague mais be est ce cette notion est ce
terme de deuxième vague de deux
troisième vague peut être un peu
trompeur parce que cela suggère que le
virus disparaîtra entre deux vagues et
ce n'est pas le cas et je crois que
c'est ce qu'on voit actuellement après
le premier pic au printemps quand le
nombre de cas a diminué les gens ont cru
que c'était fini et qu'on pouvait
revenir à la norme
c'est pourquoi j'ai toujours dit que le
virus n'est pas n'a pas disparu il est
toujours là et dès qu'on commence à nous
relâcher et à vouloir et bien reprendre
notre vie normale il va revenir et donc
voit en fait une résurgence et je pense
que ignorant encore et bien ses hauts et
ses bas ses fluctuations jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait un vaccin qui soit efficace et
disponible pour tous pour ce qui est de
l'immunité
c'est un domaine où nous n'avons pas
encore de réponse à toutes les questions
nous avons beaucoup appris concernant ce
nouveau virus au cours des huit derniers
mois mais nous n'avons pas encore tout
appris et l'un des domaines où il ya
encore beaucoup de flou et bien c'est
l'un d'entre eux c'est lui l'immunité
l'immunité est généralement mesurés par
ce que l'on appelle les antiques ordre
ce sont des protéines que le corps
produit quand il est en contact avec un
virus ou une bactérie et c'est donc
quelque chose que l'on peut mesurer nous
par le biais de tests et ces tests sont
disponibles et validés et bien il y a
des études qui ont été mis en mise en
oeuvre et et bien les résultats ont été
un petit peu décevant parce que c'est
rendu compte qu'une très faible
proportion de la population avait été en
contact avec le virus qui était bien sûr
le but du confinement on voulait éviter
que les gens entrent en contact avec le
virus donc le pourcentage de la
population et bien va de 5 à 10 ou 15%
et il y a très très peu de régions ou de
zones où cela excède 20% et c'est très
localisées sano
concerne jamais tout un pays donc ce qui
veut dire que la majorité de la
population est bien née immunisés c'est
pourquoi ces mesures de distanciation
physique ces mesures de précaution donc
ces gestes barrière se laver les mains
porter un masque doivent être maintenus
pour se protéger soi et protéger les
autres
pour ce qui est des bien eu du niveau de
préparation des hôpitaux et bien
rétrospectivement par rapport à ce qu'on
a vécu on sait maintenant qu'il ya une
chose que nous devons prendre en compte
en termes d enseignements que nous
pouvons tirer et comment nous pouvons
nous préparer
les hôpitaux sont un maillon essentiel
de cette préparation et ce différents
aspects et à la capacité à augmenter le
nombre de lits est également et bien le
nombre de professionnels de santé qui
sont disponibles parce que que se
passe-t-il si votre personnel compte
plusieurs personnes qui tombent malades
force est de constater que ça n'a pas
été le cas partout
cette capacité à aa à à intensifier les
capacités et certains pays ont pu
libérer des lits en est bien
en reportant les opérations dont
essentiels par exemple certains ont bien
monté des tentes sur d'hôpitaux de
campagne ou pour étendre leur capacité
et sa cette extension des capacités nous
devons le garder en tête pour pouvoir
être prêt à le faire si cela s'avère
nécessaire à nouveau dans les mois qui
viennent un à l'heure actuelle
autant que nous sachions il n'y a pas eu
et bien ce débordement de du système de
santé
pour l'heure les hôpitaux peuvent encore
gérer les cas
donc ça c'est une partie de la
préparation hospitalière mais il ya
également les stocks et bien de produits
et médicaments machine par exemple les
respirateurs également tout l'équipement
que j'ai mentionné pp donc le
équipements de protection masques sur
blues et c'est donc ce sont les deux
piliers si vous voulez de la préparation
du milieu hospitalier et donc j'espère
que les pays membres ont appris de ce
que nous avons vécu est également qu'
ils nous feront mieux
qu'auparavant en termes d'achats groupés
mais cela prend du temps il faut qu'il y
ait la planification de l'anticipation
merci et voilà pour cette audition de la
directrice du centre européen de
prévention et de contrôle des maladies
on va maintenant parler de nos aînés qui
ont été gravement touchés par cette
épidémie de corée navires us que ce soit
dans les ehpad ou à leur domicile les
personnes âgées ont elles été assez bien
pris en charge durant cette crise
sanitaire
les sénateurs ont interrogé le président
du conseil national professionnel de
gériatrie je vous laisse l'écouté chez
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs merci avant tout deux de
m'accueillir au sein d'autres
commissions
effectivement je représentais je
m'exprime aujourd'hui au nom du conseil
national professionnel de gériatrique
est une instance qui fédère huit
composantes nationales représentatives
des différents métiers de l'exercice
gériatrique
plus précisément une société savante
société française de gériatrie
gérontologie le collège national des
enseignants de gériatrie universitaire
deux fédérations et associations de
médecins coordonnateurs de hp à des
départs
le syndicat national des gens rentrent
au gie clinique
le syndicat csmf des médecins
coordinateurs les médecins gériatres
libéraux également et enfin
l'association des jeunes gériatre
l'ensemble des instances alors vous dire
d'abord que nos instances ont entretenu
des liens extrêmement rapprochés assez
rapidement au cours de cette crise
puisque les dates font état du fait que
des
la mi mars nous avons été amenés
entretient des relations très proches
avec nos différents cabinets damman
ministère des solidarités de la santé un
peu plus un peu plus tard avec cabinet
de matignon mais aussi avec nos
administrations centrales
la dgcs qui organisait des réunions
mensuelles de madère auquel j'ai
personnellement participé
la dg os également les ars au niveau
régional
et puis on a été aussi en lien est
interrogé par le conseil scientifique et
par le haut conseil de santé publique
donc on a clairement été à plusieurs
reprises l'objet de saisine
questionnement venant de ces différentes
instances et je voudrais vous en donner
les grandes lignes par déjà une première
correspondance qui date du 20 mars nous
a amenés avec dix autres organismes
nationaux représentatifs du secteur
les fédérations hospitalières fhf fait
appel le synerpa des différentes
associations volant dati aussi des
directeurs d'établissement du domicile
l'uniopss la fondation partage et vit un
certain nombre d'organismes
on a donc voulu attirer l'attention de
nos ministères sur le sujet dès les
équipements de protection individuelle
et partisan des masques en faisant
mention du fait qui nous semblait urgent
de faire en sorte de mettre à
disposition ses matchs notamment au sein
des ehpad
mais aussi au sein des services dell à
domicile et on avait donc estimé à 500
mille le nombre de masques par jour
nécessaire savoir se sentent masque pour
année pas de 80 places soit 5 masques
par jour donc la cible qui nous avait
été qu'on avait donc proposé pour
couvrir les besoins
cinq cent mille masques par jour pour
pour les ehpad uniquement pour réside
pas dans cette même correspondance on
faisait mention de notre inquiétude sur
l'accès à l'hospitalisation vais revenir
notamment des résidents d pad et donc à
la suite de cette première
correspondance les mesures que on était
donc mise en place pour doter ces
établissements
désopilant en particulier des masques ça
s'est fait de manière graduelle à partir
de 7 cette première correspondance une
seconde correspondance qui date du 26
mars elle attire l'attention sur la
nécessité d'identifier alors on est
plutôt dans le champ des ehpad mais ceci
s'applique autant aux personnes à
domicile dès lors quelles sont les
personnes vulnérables je parle donc des
personnes âgées particulièrement des
personnes de plus de 75 ans au des
personnes qui présentent des
polypathologies les comorbidités
prévalente qui comme vous savez ce
constituer un facteur de risque de
l'infection et surtout un facteur de
gravité pronostics et donc on a jeté
bien différencier trois situations pour
lesquelles les réponses peuvent pas être
tout à fait identique la première
d'entre elles concerne les résidents qui
sont dans ces établissements et qui sont
dans des situations soient de soins
palliatifs soit de fin de vie pour les
qualifications
considérons que la prise en soin de tête
assuré
là où ils sont hébergés une seconde
situation qui concerne des résidents qui
présente suspicion de co vide et dont le
pronostic vital n'est a priori pas je
regarde de leur mobilité donc de leur
état personnellement aussi au regard des
premières manifestations de la maladie
et une troisième situation qui est bien
évidemment la situation redoute air
savoir une infection survenant sur des
organismes
beaucoup plus vulnérable parce que comme
morbide et surtout avec déjà des signes
de détresse respiratoire ou en tout cas
des formes cliniques beaucoup plus
préoccupante justifiant le recours à
l'hospitalisation en rappelant qu'
effectivement ces établissements par
leurs histoires ne sont pas ne sont pas
à même aujourd'hui d'assurer une prise
en soins continus au regard de ces
situations intercurrente j'ai des
résidents des patients qui sont à risque
de décompensation d'organes la maladie
en l'occurrence l'aco vide étant un des
facteurs pronostiques directement mais
aussi indirectement par le fait qu'il
soit bien sûr les organismes extrêmement
fragilisée je rappelle que la permanence
infirmières n'est pas sûr et la nuit
notamment dans ces établissements
donc à cela on a donc annoncé neuf
mesures pour atténuer l'impact dans
l'infection à qu'ovide sur les personnes
âgées dépendantes résidents des potes ou
à domicile
première de ces mesures je vais être
extrêmement bref le ces documents soient
vos dispositions sont de garantir
l'accès aux supputations des résidents
et des personnes âgées vivant à domicile
suspecté ou confirmés dont le pronostic
vital est engagé
donc la situation que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure deuxième mesure 7 permettre le
recours à l'expertisé ria tricks et en
soins palliatifs renforçant les moyens
dédiés aux équipe mobile de gériatrie
soins palliatifs qui se déplace dans les
établissements troisième mesure de cette
facilité l'accès la réalisation des
tests pcr au sein des ehpad et domicile
pour garantir les conditions et garantir
leurs conditions de réalisation la
quatrième mesure c'est de renforcer
l'encadrement médical et soignant des
ehpad garantir le financement du période
s'affirmèrent de huy la cinquième c'est
d'assurer la permanence de gériatres 24
heures sur 24 par territoire ce qui a
été mis en place à travers les
plateformes j'y reviendrai 6e mesure
c'est de mettre à disposition les
molécules réservé puisque ce jour à
l'usagé hospitalier je pense notamment
aux planeyse est pas mais enfin
certaines nombre de molécules qui ont
fait l'objet d'ailleurs dû d'un décret
quelques jours après permettant
effectivement la délivrance
ces molécules dans ces établissements la
7e mesure c'est d'élargir les
autorisations de prescription du médecin
coordonnateur
dans cette situation exceptionnelle la
huitième c'est de permettre la mise en
oeuvre par l'infirmière de la
prescription réalisées à distance par le
médecin et enfin la neuvième c'est
d'engagement rapidement un essai
clinique
donc on est plus sur le volet recherche
ces mesures ont dans la plupart pour la
plupart d'entre elles étaient donc suivi
de réponse via certain nombre de
directives d'instruction de fiches j'ai
eu si par exemple une fiche ars intitulé
stratégie de prise en charge des
personnes âgées en établissement et à
domicile en cas d'ingestion d'épidémie
de kobe 19 qui reprend en grande partie
ces éléments que je viens d'évoquer un
des points sur lequel on a insisté c'est
laborieux un logigramme d'eads à la
décision pour aider les à la prise de
décision en situation on est pas
notamment des différents professionnels
quand elle l'orientation vers
l'hospitalisation
cet algorithme prend en compte d'un
certain nombre de paramètres qui
reprennent bien sûr l'état de santé
précédent de la personne le pronostic
estimé sur des scores et bien évidemment
tenant compte aussi des directives
anticipées
je voudrais également mentionné une
correspondance qui elle date du 10 avril
et qui attire l'attention sur les
risques potentiels induits par le
confinement est donc tout les effets
délétères du confinement et les
précautions à prendre pour éviter
justement ces effets secondaires ont
mentionné à ce moment là la nécessité de
pouvoir mettre en place les solutions
impliquant l'ensemble des professionnels
de santé libéraux médecins généralistes
spécialistes kinésithérapeute
ergothérapeute psychologue je vais pas
lister tout c'est donc ces professions
libérales
j'ai presque fini enfin une
correspondance qui date du 11 avril qui
a trait aux tests à la demande non du
cabinet ou non a été amené
à la définir une doctrine quand
l'indication l'horizon des tests
notamment en ehpad en insistant sur la
nécessité effectivement de tester dès
qu'un premiers résidents étaient ou
soignant était suspecté l'ensemble des
résidents et soignons enfin pour rester
dans le temps imparti vous dire que tout
cela s'est traduit une fine et par la
révision du manifeste que nous avions
élaboré en 2019 qui comportait en son
temps 15 mesures et qui en comporte
désormais 22 c 22 mesures sont pas le
temps de les développer je répondrais
éventuellement aux questions mais
reprennent pour un grand nombre un
certain nombre de points qui sont des
dispositifs qui ont fait leurs preuves
pendant cette crise je bois notamment
des plateformes gériatrique interface
ehpad hôpital domicile donc je vais vous
pourrez répondre aux questions la
nécessité aussi de revoir la dotation
des ehpad en matière de moyens humains
donc on a élaboré notamment le le ratio
soignants minimale pour année pas de 80
places également la cité revoir ses
domiciles et notamment permettre aux
médecins de se déplacer plus volontiers
au domicile et tenir compte de la
spécificité des personnes à domicile qui
sont gir 1 2 ou 3 et qui se déplace
difficilement c'est nécessairement tous
a assorti de mesures ayant trait à la
spécialité joueurs présentent à savoir
la nécessité de revoir peut-être aussi
est certainement le nombre de gériatres
qualifié pour pouvoir ces deux fonctions
je vais m'arrêter là pour respecter le
temps et vous remercie de votre
attention
merci voilà on est nous sommes dans une
commission d enquête
alors donc c'est le travail par rapport
à la crise après il y avait tout le
problème de gériatres mais ça c'est pas
aujourd'hui que nous allons les régler
donc vous avez souhaité être auditionné
vous avez attiré l'attention du
ministère vous avez été écoutés pour
partie parce qu'il y avait un nombre de
morts quand même important dans les
ehpad c'est des questions composez-vous
haut-commissaire et
donc on cherche à savoir comment on
pourra justement éviter étiré expérience
de ce qu'ils veulent on a connu donc
votre aide peut-être précieuse me
semble-t-il
je vais passer la parole au rapporteur
puisque pour que vous puissiez répondre
à leur question individuellement je
commence par sylvie vers minuit vous
alternez trois rapports merci monsieur
le président merci professeur de votre
exposé liminaire
je vais vous poser une seule question je
réagis par rapport au neuf mesures que
vous avez décliné la première c'est
garantir l'accès à l'hospitalisation de
toute personne en ehpad qui
présenteraient des des difficultés enfin
des cas un cas grave
est ce que ça suppose que ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
alors effectivement dans la région
notamment dans le grand test dans les
premières régions touchées ça n'a pas
donc la réponse n'a pas été
immédiatement adapté parce qu'il y avait
un effet de sidération simplement raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs on a proposé de
couvrir l'ensemble de l'offre sanitaire
aussi bien service de médecine que de
soins de suite que des hôpitaux de
proximité pour accueillir des résidents
ou des personnes à domicile qui ne
nécessitaient pas toujours recours à la
réanimation mais simplement une
surveillance permanence des soins et une
surveillance médicale et infirmière
continue vous pouvez quantifier est-ce
que vous avez une idée du nombre de
personnes en ehpad qui
on apprend malheureusement on s'expose
pas de cette information
il y a des éléments indirects qui sont
dans les camps ont été publiés quand on
regarde par exemple la répartition en
fonction de l'âge du recours aux
services d'urgences
on a l'impression que les process
d'urgence pas de régulation pression
qu'il ya proportionnellement la
proportion des plus de 75 ans n'est pas
corrélé en fait que cette population a
été plus impactées donc on pourrait à
travers cette information
supposez que effectivement cette
population n'a pas à pas à pas et est
amené plus aussi facilement que les
autres tranches d'âge à accéder à cette
mesure aux urgences ce sont des éléments
indirects je ne dispose malheureusement
pas d'éléments plus plus précis merci
catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président moi j'avais
deux questions la première
michèle delaunay spécialiste en effet du
grand âge s'est exprimé en disant que
les allemands avaient pu être terrible
pour les personnes âgées comment vous
voyez en effet même d'une erreur comment
vous voyez en effet la gestion de
dans les établissements de cet isolement
et quelles en sont les causes que vous
voyez en terme de pénurie de pays où
pénurie de test et le deuxième point
c'est la situation actuelle où on voit
des des établissements dans lesquels des
cas positifs sont détectés en ce moment
est un exemple dans une maison de n'est
pas de l'aveyron il ya d'autres
départements à la fois dans le personnel
aidant les résidents comment quelle est
votre vision actuelle
aujourd'hui de la situation des
personnes des personnes âgées
deuxième question et façon répondre à la
première
le confinement tel qu'il a été mis en
oeuvre avait pour but de protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables
nous avions dénoncé le fait que pour 1
n'est pas notamment dès lors qu'on
laissait le virus entrer dans
l'établissement le risque était grand
qui est une chaîne de contamination et
on sait très bien que le vecteur
premiers sont les soignants elle évite
bien sûr les proches donc aujourd'hui
pour répondre à votre deuxième question
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où les
mesures barrières sont strictement
respectées par ces deux vecteurs
on est dans une situation bien
différente et qui ne nécessitera pas de
recourir un nouveau confinement jeu voir
les personnes qui ne sont pas infectés
mois d'avant les cas infectés
l'homme est isolé en matière de
prévention la contamination de résidents
l'application stricte des mesures
barrières stricte doit permettre
d'éviter éviter cette transmission
donc les établissements dans l'est au
sein desquels on constate des premiers
cas sont des situations où il ya vecteur
qui étaient soit soignants soins
c'est un proche qui n'a peut-être pas
pris les précautions seraient si on veut
éviter encore une fois leur confier tous
les effets secondaires de ce confinement
sur ces organismes extrêmement fragile
c'est clair il est impératif d'appliquer
ces mesures barrières stricte et de
réaliser des tests dès lors qu'on a le
quelconque suspicion d'un cas soignants
ou d'un proche
c'est cette forme elle si nous avions eu
le matériel nécessaire pour se protéger
on aurait vu peut-être moins de rester
au niveau des établissements
alors on peut on peut l'être on peut le
présupposé sachant que ce ne soit qu'une
question de matériel ces questions ces
deux comportements de procédure et terre
qu'il ya du matériel il ya des
procédures des procédures aussi de de
vérification que ces procédures sont
bien en place
donc un contrôle et puis l'éducation le
comprends je rappelle que le le
comportement de vis-à-vis de l'hygiène
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises on est
rappelé un peu à l'ordre toussaint
concernant donc les bonnes pratiques de
l'hygiène que ce soit dans les solutions
sanitaire où on est peut-être plus armée
parce que par habitude mais ça d'epargne
pourtant pas secteur dans le secteur
médico-social et eaux de vie celle
évidemment ces pratiques hygiéniste
n'était peut-être pas suffisamment
appliquée merci bernard jomier merci
monsieur le président merci pour vos
propos il faudrait poursuit sur la
question de catherine ii roche qui
reprend les propos de michèle delaunay
sur l' isolement des personnes âgées
en fait je
j'ai entendu dans les dents ce que
disait michel delaunay qu'au fond une
question de fond qui est revenu dans les
propos du csn quelle légitimité at on de
décider d'un isolement de personnes
âgées qui n'ont pas de troubles
cognitifs massif on va dire qu'ils ont
leur libre arbitre et leur volonté est
ce que parce qu on a 75 81 85 ans et
qu'on réside dans un habitat collectif
on doit être soumis à une décision et
non pas choisir soi-même
au fond si on veut assumer un risque ou
aussi on voit là ou si on veut on
accepte une contrainte de d'isolement
social et j'ai une question de fond pour
nous et pour notre société j'aurais aimé
que vous nous disiez comment votre votre
votre instance affronte cette question
du libre choix et du fait que personne
âgée ne signifie pas infantilisation
renoncement à exercer un droit
et puis j'ai une deuxième question cette
épidémie elle nous a surpris par
beaucoup d'aspects mais il ya un aspect
sur lequel elle nous a pas surpris c'est
que on a su très vite parce qu'on avait
l'épidémie en chine sous les yeux au
mois de février que les personnes plus
on était âgé et plus on était à risque
et plus et que les décès se produisait
dans les catégories de population est
plus élevé et puis certaines conditions
de morbidité et donc avant même que la
vague pour le coup ne déferle dans notre
pays
on savait que c'est cette catégorie de
population allaient être
particulièrement touchés quelle a été la
parole moi je n'ai pas entendu la parole
des gériatres au mois de février mais
vous allez pouvoir peut-être nous
démentir quelques ailes
comment vous êtes vous préparé qu'est ce
que vous avez dit aux pouvoirs publics à
ce moment là qu'elle est quelles ont été
vos positions est-ce que vous avez été
sollicité pendant cette période là c'est
semaine là au vu de l'épidémie en chine
pour préparer on va dire le monde de la
gériatrie à protéger
personnes âgées à préparer leur prise en
charge sur la première question vous
avez bien fait de différencier donc les
deux situations de personnes qui ont ou
non des troubles cognitifs bon
malheureusement en ehpad
vous savez 88 80 % ont des troubles de
la cohérence qui témoigne de troubles du
jugement du raisonnement qui ne
permettent pas ces personnes de se
rendre compte des risques qu'ils
encourent donc là on est contraints
qu'ils soient sous protection juridique
a fortiori ou pas de prendre les
précautions j'irai en considérant que ça
fait partie des responsabilités
collectives
s'agissant des personnes alors je n'aime
pas ce terme de personnages et pourrait
discuter longuement c'est un terme
impropre
la jeune et un pas pour nous un
paramètre suffisamment pertinent pour
catégoriser donc on va dire les
personnes qui avancent en lâche gratter
un certain âge avec le risque plus élevé
de commencer à présenter des trous mais
dès lors qu'ils n'en présente pas ce
dont vous parlez je ne vois pas pourquoi
on lit distinguerait des autres donc
pour nous pas de différence entre une
personne y compris riverains 10 ans et
une personne de 50 ans dès lors qu'est
la notion de mais pourtant leur a pas
laissé le choix à ces personnes là n'ont
play et donc vis-à-vis de ces personnes
là il est important de vérifier
simplement qu'elles ont eu l'information
requise qu'elles l'ont comprise et
qu'elles ont les enjeux les risques
qu'elle encourait à titre perd pour elle
mais aussi pour leurs proches d'ailleurs
et dès lors que c'est le cas il n'y a
pas de raison de faire différemment
vis-à-vis de quelqu'un qui en pleine
possession de ses moyens
voilà notre doctrine à paris
voilà c'est pas ce qui a été fait donc
vous voilà donc vous vous donnez un peu
corps aux propos de michèle delaunay
pour ce qui est des personnes ne
présentant pas de troubles cognitifs
massif on est bien d'accord
la grande difficulté ce sens les
personnes vulnérables
ce ne sont pas celles là ce sont celles
qui présentent des troubles
kiki et qui les ignorent qu'ils sont
méconnus parce que isolé donc il ya eu
rapport ce guedj fait un rapport sur ce
sujet des personnes isolées pour tenter
d'aller vers ces personnes d identifier
de manière à ne pas les laisser pour
compte et vérifier qu'elles ont elles
mêmes été informés qu'on a mis en place
les l'application des mesures les
concernant
sur ce point là clairement c'est un
enjeu majeur de société qui devient fort
travaillait très fort parce que cette
crise a révélé beaucoup de fragilité
aussi c'en est une sur la question la
deuxième question vous posez qui a trait
à à notre position au moment où la crise
s'est déclarée en chine clairement c'est
à partir du moment où il y a eu le
premier foyer dans le grand est ce que
nous avons été véritablement parce que
tout ça on était au premier en prise
directe je crois que vous avez été amené
à auditionner certains de mes collègues
qui étaient dans cette région clairement
on n'avait pas le temps de faire autre
chose que de gérer la crise on était la
tête dans le guidon à traiter les
situations telle qu'elle se présentait
on était loin de pouvoir s'exprimer sur
des sujets comme ceux que vous évoquez
nous ne sommes pas très nombreuses
images et peut-être que nous sommes un
grand corps professionnels nous sommes
assez peu nombreux donc la plupart
d'entre nous sommes
sur le terrain à pratiquer notre
exercice
tant mieux si j'entends grand test ça
veut dire au début mars quoi si
j'entends grand test c'est début mars
voilà oui parce que nous on a constaté
moi je suis élu du grand test on a
constaté qu'effectivement les personnes
âgées n'étaient pas prises en compte
preuve en est c'est dans le décompte des
décès journaliers les ehpad sont venus 8
à 10 jours après et si nous n'avions pas
alerter et par le biais du département
les mêmes la rs etc
il y aurait un retard encore plus
accentuées mais c'est vrai que la vague
a été tellement brutale s'était
largement expliqué que maintenant
l'expérience at elle été tirés c'est ce
que si je me permets tu si vous évoquez
les ai pas n'oublions pas le domicile on
a moins d'informations sur lui c'est
tout à fait vrai mais ça montre aussi
que nos établissements médico-sociaux
j'élargis au sens du handicap n'était
pas armé à la différence des solutions
sanitaires ne serait ce que par le fait
qu' ils ont des pratiques douces ali
sanitaire départ et surtout ils ont les
moyens humains une médicalisation certes
bien différente donc d'abord je dirais
tous les ehpad un grand nombre d pad ont
su faire face
j'ai quand même la grande majorité tire
ont d'ailleurs profité des premières
informations et le son de l'est quand
même pour autant c'est un secteur qui
reste quand même fragile au regard de la
population qui l'accueille
je rappelle que depuis la création des
états qui date de 1999 fait plus de 20
ans si vous regardez les indicateurs qui
vous définissent les profils de besoins
en termes de soins ou d'accompagnement
les fameux pmp gmp
c'est ça grimpe 1 c'est à dire qu'on a
plus du tout à faire aujourd'hui à la
population qu'on accueillait il ya vingt
ans la création et même ya 10 ans et ça
va peut-être se poursuivre encore dont
on n'a pas à adapter les ressources à 7
ces deux éléments là qui sont des
éléments majeurs alors qu'il faut c'est
l'objet de nos mesures
je pourrais revenir dessus qui nécessite
impérativement de se repencher sur le
modèle de l'époque les pas d'aujourd'hui
est elle à la résidence d'autonomie
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas d'hier elle
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui ressemble plutôt
à soins de longue durée on fait glisser
la raison les populations donc il faut
réagir c'est assez vite
et puisque la moyenne d'un de d'âge de
l'ehpad et à plus de 80 ans l'âge et le
niveau de dépendance au moment où la
personne est accueilli bien super durée
de séjour moyen pour finir ses jours
dans deux ans deux ans de ça faut le
rappeler c'est vrai n'appelle pas à ses
soins merci aux rapporteurs c'est bon
très bien je passe aux questions des
commissaires g4 rap quatre commissaires
qui ont des questions laurence cohen on
va grouiller merci monsieur le président
et merci professeur parmi parmi les
leçons effectivement que nous nous donne
cette cette pandémie
en tout cas au niveau des personnes qui
atteignent un certain âge ou voilà
je trouve qu'il ya quand même et ça
prolonge les questions de nous deux nous
rapporteure catherine desrochers bernard
jomier ça pose quand même la question du
libre arbitre de ses résidents
évidemment quand je dis ça je parle de
personnes qui n'ont pas de troubles
cognitifs et qui sont en capacité de
jugement
or on voit bien que là il ya quelque
chose qui est noeud qui ne va pas c'est
à dire que les décisions sont prises
sans eux en dehors d'eux et ils
subissent ces décisions donc il ya un
déficit d'une manière globale au niveau
de notre système sanitaire de ce qu'on
appelle la démocratie sanitaire
il y a un manque à gagner concernant la
prise en compte des en a reçues lors de
nos auditions des associations de
patients qui ne sont pas associés à aux
prises de décision et là on voit avec la
crise du coc vite
l'acuité de 2,2 ce manque et c'est c'est
quand même un à une problématique
évidemment pour les professionnels qui
s'occupent des ehpad et des soins à
domicile etc
mais c'est une problématique de la
société tout entière est ce qu'on
considère qu'à partir du moment où une
personne atteint certaines âge il n'a
plus une citoyenneté pleine et entière
pour pouvoir avoir le libre arbitre
c'est vraiment une question qui me
semble fondamental et ça rejoint aussi
me semble-t-il ce qu'on a entendu ce
matin avec la représentante de ronaldo
qui a aussi posé cette question là en
terme d'ailleurs du pouvoir du pouvoir
très important médicale à l'égard des
patients où elle a dit elle nous a
alertés sur le fait de maintenir le
droit des patients au niveau individuel
droit à l'information est la décision
médicale partagée
donc on voit bien là qui est une dérive
quand même de notre système jean et qui
datent pas de
roduit donc quel est votre votre
approche par rapport à cet état de fait
et comment est ce que vous essayez de
travailler pour dépasser et pour est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que là il ya
une prise de conscience des pouvoirs
publics ou pas et pour terminer
j'entendais un reportage sur france
inter je crois que c'était samedi et il
y avait une dame qui était dans un ehpad
une dame de 102 ans bon pied bon oeil et
elle témoignait du fait qu'elle était
navré de sa privation de liberté parce
qu'elle ne pouvait plus se déplacer
quand elle sortait il y avait tout un
protocole de désinfection de ses
vêtements et elle était coincée dans sa
chambre je ne dis pas que ces mesures
n'étaient pas nécessaires mais je dis
que les conditions dans lesquelles elles
sont prises se font en dehors de la
personne et dont il n'ya pas adhésion et
ça peut entraîner y compris ce qu'on
appelle des phénomènes de glissements
parce qu'il ya quand même des gens qui
de par les allemands ne sont pas mortes
du coup vite mais où sont mortes du fait
d'être au sol donc voilà comment est ce
que tout ça se peut être dépassé je vous
remercie
roger karoutchi le professeur moi je
viens d'un département les
hauts-de-seine où il ya à peu près 120
ehpad qui ont été très durement touché
pendant la crise
l'immense majorité de nos ehpad ont eu
des cas des cas graves
bon avec de nombreux décès donc c'est un
département qui a vraiment craqué sur ce
côté et j'en viens ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure est ce que c'est pas la
conception des ehpad qui doit être
modifié quand on regarde de manière
brutale
les chiffres de décès entre
les ceux qui sont morts dans les ehpad
ou ceux qui en venant des ehpad sont
morts à l'hôpital parce qu'ils ont sont
quand même allés à l'hôpital
on est globalement entre quinze et seize
mille décès pour les gens issus des
epode dans la même tranche d'âge
sept cent mille résidents ehpad à peu
près 5 millions de français chez eux si
je puis dire à la tranche d'âge entre
ceux qui sont décédés malheureusement
chez eux et ceux qui sont décédés à
l'hôpital
on est pratiquement aux mêmes chiffres
c'est à dire que on a eu quinze ou seize
mille idées c'est sur cette somme ils
résident l'ehpad et quinze ou seize
mille décès sur cinq millions de
personnes de la même tranche d'âge que
ceux des ehpad
mais qui c'est qui étaient chez eux
alors parce que la vraie question et ça
rejoint mais indirectement ce qu'on dit
laurent c est probablement catherine le
vrai sujet c'est est-ce que la
conception de l'ehpad ya 20 ans n'ait
pas dépassé
est ce qu'en réalité il faut pas trouver
des solutions aujourd'hui alors je sais
bien que on va nous dire c'est
impossible de faire de telles
sectorisation ça va créer encore des
différenciations qui seront pas
supportés par la société mais c'est
évident que quand vous dites il ya
aujourd'hui une majorité de gens en
ehpad qui n'ont pas toutes leurs
capacités cognitives et qui par
conséquent ne se rendent même pas compte
qu'elles se mettent en danger de mort
donc il faut décider pour elle le vrai
sujet c'est qu'on dit ça pour peut-être
je sais pas 70 pour cent soixante treize
pour sage en ehpad
mais sur le coup les 25 4% qui ont
toutes leurs facultés sont traités de la
même manière et donc il ya à la fois
est-ce qu'on peut pas trouver pour
l'avenir des solutions pour que la
manière d'être le fonctionnement des
ehpad soit modifié pour qu'on n'est pas
en réalité ces situations là où ce qui
pourrait décider par eux-mêmes exercer
leur propre liberté leur propre vie
ne sois pas là les mêmes conditions et
quelque part est ce que malheureusement
la mortalité en ehpad n'est pas un
élément déterminant pour se dire ça
n'est pas possible de continuer avec le
même système qui n'est pas en situation
de sauver les gens
parce que on avait l'impression
franchement dans le département des
hauts-de-seine moi je ne savais plus
quoi dire au préfet on avait parfois le
sentiment que à partir du moment où les
gens étaient en ehpad et où il y avait
des cas c'était fini c'était quasiment
on ne savait pas en attendait juste de
savoir qui pourrait survivre ce qui est
épouvantable enfin donc y est ce qu'il
faut pas trouver maintenant des
solutions pour éviter ce genre de
situation donc effectivement c'est ça
rejoint la question de monsieur jomier
force qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez la
question d'abord c'est d'informer
largement des droits parce que j'ai été
exceptionnellement sollicité pour
l'élaboration de mandat de protection
juridique
pourtant cette règle existe elle permet
à chacun d'anticiper jour serait plus à
même de pouvoir prendre la décision
d'anticiper de transmettre à sa personne
de confiance va pas directives
anticipées là la possibilité d'une mise
sous protection
cette mesure on y est
moi en tant que médecin gré je suis
extrêmement peu sollicité à délivrer ce
type de certificats donc il ya
certainement un tract d'information
parce que les les textes existent mais
sont pas utiles ne sont pas connues ont
c'est un élément de réponse
je rappelle que dès lors qu'on accueille
à un nouveau résident dans un
établissement médico social
on est amené à instruire ce qu'on
appelle le plan l'accompagnement
personnalisé qui consiste à connaître la
personne dans son histoire de vie sont
ceux son historicité sont ses besoins
ses attentes et d'élaborer le plan de
réponse à cela
individuels personnalisés cette mesure
elle existe elle est appliquée dans la
majorité des établissements
la difficulté c'est que vous l'avez dit
monsieur tout à l'heure la les personnes
qui sont accueillis en ehpad aujourd'hui
on sont accueillis dans des situations
beaucoup plus extrêmes qu'ils ne
l'étaient il y a dix quinze ans
précédemment on avait on programmait une
admission l'époque on l'a programmé
aujourd'hui larmes plus de la moitié
viennent de l'hôpital c'est à dire que
ce sont des personnes qui vont être
orientées en ehpad
après avoir été hospitalisé mais ils ont
été hospitalisés parce que il était dans
une situation de crise au sens où ils
ont osé compenser une maladie chronique
où il y a eu une rupture de l'étayage y
avait plus des dents
tout ça une situation qui n'était pas
prévisible survient devenir assez brutal
la seule réponse qu'on essaie
l'hospitalisation et bien sûr c'est
l'hôpital qui va ensuite préparer
l'orientation vers l'est pas
d'embrouillés on n'est plus du tout dans
cette situation de progrès de
préparation or il ya comme vous dites
monsieur karoutchi l'écrit particulier
ça ça complique c'est que c'est pas
homogène et dans un ehpad des
sous-populations jeu paraît très
technique mais on a les profils de soins
le pathos là qui nous donne déjà des
profils de soins requis serre il ya
c'est un éventail de besoins vraie
différence et la population et pas
homogène en termes de soins en termes
d'accompagnement non plus et il y avait
effectivement un certain pourcentage de
personnes qui ont des niveaux de
commissions de commissions encore assez
préservé
vous avez oublié cette dalle de 102 ans
mais dans la mesure où ils sont dans un
établissement collectif on applique des
règles collectives
le site serait la restauration se fait
caricatural et donc la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est de remettre le modèle
qui peut le réaliser ce modèle pour
essayer de mieux personnaliser les
réponses répondre aux attentes quand ils
ont pu l ont pu être exprimées ou
recueillis et effectivement il faut
tenir compte des profils de soins
on attendait dans les ehpad et personnes
qui sont dans des unités protégées parce
qu'ils présentent des troubles du
comportement qui font que devrait
densifier protéger et puis ces mêmes
personnes cohabitent avec d'autres
personnes qui n'ont pas trop du
comportement donc on voit je vais pas
développer on voit que c'est devenu une
situation complexe
on accueille des personnes en situation
de handicap vieillissants sont plus
jeunes parce que parce qu'il n'ya pas de
structures idoines
on accueille des populations migrent en
vieillissant dont ces établissements je
rappelle au début n'était pas n'avait
pas vocation à accueillir tous
toutes ces typologies différencier alors
mettez vous à la place des
professionnels à qui on demande d'être
bon dans tout ça aussi c'est un élément
qui a un impact sur l'attractivité et
qui crée pour les personnels et un
confort des frustrations pas pouvoir
bien faire justement parce qu'on peut
pas demander à nos étudiants d'être
capable de traiter toutes ces situations
silva rien ça ça renvoie sur les métiers
aussi est important de revoir
complètement effectivement le modèle pas
si je répondu il expand sow part si nous
allons passer aux questions suivantes
pour la réponse est bon roger un hoquet
victoire jasmin merci monsieur le
président alors monsieur fils de reste à
voir si vous avez dans ses différents
établissements des procédures dégradé
concernant la chaîne de décision et la
continuité des activités en fonction des
différents professionnels et la dernière
chose devrait évoquer justement lors
d'une des auditions organisées par ma
collègue madame corinne féret il ya
quelques mois et un responsable
d'association avait évoqué la situation
d'une infirmière lanceur dalet denis
parent d'élève de nepad qui a été
révoqué parce qu'elle avait annoncé
qu'il y avait un nombre trop important
de personnes qui mouraient dans cette
8ème dans cette crise et pas de pardon
et cette personne a eu des problèmes de
santé est actuellement d'après les
informations que j'ai eu une
décompensation dans un établissement
psychiatrique
alors est-ce que vous pensez que qu'on
pouvait pas éviter cette situation on a
souvent parlé de souffrance de
professionnels mais arrivé à ce stade
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez et c'est
vraiment dommage en tout cas j'ai
entendu que vous avez dit et l'autre
chose c'est que on a eu des quantités
quand même importante de personnes qui
sont décédées dans les ehpad et donc
votre dans votre intervention on ne
ressent pas qu'il y a eu quand même des
situations dramatiques ou des familles
pour les proches
et les personnes qui sont les victimes
on aurait pu sauver également donc on
n'a pas personnellement je n'ai pas
ressenti une partie de votre
intervention qui pourrait évoquer cette
partie de la situation que nous venons
de vivre
merci merci hoenig limo oui merci
monsieur le président professeur pendant
confinement il y à des professionnels de
santé qui n'ont pas pu rentrer dans les
ehpad
je pense notamment aux kinésithérapeutes
donc je voulais avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus d'autant que lors des audits
de l'audition avec les ordres la semaine
dernière certains nous ont dit qu à
nouveau des ehpad fermé leurs portes à
certains professionnels de santé donc je
voudrais avoir votre réaction et angèle
préville monsieur le président donc
merci monsieur le professeur de répondre
par avance à ma question
donc je reviens sur la situation et du
nombre de décès qui a été évoqué par par
d'autres collègues
quels enseignements peut tirer de ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'est
effectivement ça a était grave et
dramatique
on avait déjà eu la canicule avec un
nombre de décès important est ce que et
la canicule c'était déjà il ya quelques
années
est-ce qu'on avait tiré les conséquences
de ce qui s'était passé
est ce que est ce qu'il y a quelqu'un je
sais pas la tête je ne sais pas quelle
organisation qui aurait dû tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé et et appelé à la
vigilance je n'ai moi il me semble que
je n'ai pas entendu ça et moi j'ai
alerté j'ai posé une une question j'ai
eu la réponse à une question écrite j'ai
eu la réponse il ya quelques jours
c'était des 2 avril pour demander qui
est des protections parce que dans les
ehpad près de chez moi dans le lot il
n'ya il n'avait pas vous n'avez pas les
protections nécessaires et donc
fatalement alors que mon département a
été très peu touchés et bien dans tous
les établissements autour de autour de
moi les quatre vraiment dans quelques
kilomètres la moitié des résidants été
testé positif
je pense qu'on aurait pu quand même
anticiper plus quoi davantage et puis
est ce que la prochaine fois qu'on a un
autre une autre alors pas forcément
pandémie mais un autre épisode qui
affecterait les personnes âgées on va se
retrouver face à nouveau un nombre de
décès important voilà merci mais c'est
le professeur mais je pense à avoir
répondu tout à l'heure je n'ai pas
révoquer les chiffes parce que je pense
que les chiffres sont son public
évidemment que on les a regardés de très
près tout tous les jours on a réagi
d'ailleurs par un certain nombre de
dettes aurions donc je ne pensais pas
utile de le rappeler bien évidemment la
question c'est plutôt de comprendre et
de trouver les réponses bien sûr pour
éviter que cette situation ne se
renouvelle le comprendre je crois qu'on
a évoqué tous les déterminants les
pratiques hygiéniques
je pars faire ce que j'ai à exprimer les
pratiques eugéniques
las la formation à l'hygiène le recours
aux cellules d'hygiène les bons réflexes
les interfaces avec le sanitaire puisque
en fait ce qui a quand même joué un rôle
important pour réduire les risques
c'est le lien qui ont qui a pu s'établir
avec les filières hospitalière les
ferrière gériatrique et les autres
filières hospitalière avec leurs
cellules d'hygiène laisser pias les
équipes mobiles qui se sont déplacés
dans les ehpad pour donner conseils un
certain nombre de médecins qui ont
assuré le rôle de médecin coordonnateur
quand il n'y avait pas de mettre cinq
orateurs pas tout ça je pense que c'est
ça et écrit le sujet des libéraux de
l'accès des kinés
d autres nationale effectivement dans la
situation du risque de transmission par
tous professionnels on a considéré qu'il
y avait un risque jusqu'à pouvoir lever
ce risque dès lors que ces mêmes
professionnels étaient en mesure
d'appliquer les mesures barrières mais
il ya eu effectivement un délai pour
cela ça c'est clair
ensuite il faut rappeler on a évoqué sur
le modèle de l'ehpad qui n'était pas
préparé à assurer la fin de vie de ces
dans cette situation particulièrement
angoissante terrifiante pour les
soignants l'alternative c'est l'accès à
l'hospitalisation
on a attiré l'attention sur le fait
qu'il fallait ouvrir toutes les lignes
d'hospitalisation j'ai pas les hôpitaux
de proximité de manière à ne pas se
limiter aux urgences et au siège de
réanimation mais bien l'ensemble de
l'offre sanitaire pour éviter justement
que ces établissements médico sociaux
qui n'ont pas les moyens de pouvoir
assurer la meilleure prise en soin d'en
situation puisse orienter leur président
envers ces établissements sanitaires les
unités qu'ovide ont été créés moi je
suis d'une autre région que l'est dans
ma région en particulier tout ça a été
mis en place
donc c'est ce sont toutes ces aides le
son là qu'il faut maintenant à appliquer
revoir en détail et surtout renforcer
puis les rendre durable surtout pérenne
parce que il ya cette crise il y aura
d'autres crises
ça nous a montré quand même que les
cloisonnements entre le sanitaire le
médico social et social classique
nécessite bref véritablement qu'on
trouve les solutions de ce cloisonnement
et concret des plateformes d interface
beaucoup plus opérationnels pour pouvoir
faire face à ces situations
et puis renforcé renforcer les
établissements en moyens humains et en
en médicalisation ça veut dire
clairement qu'il faut médicalisé
établissements et peut-être j'ai pas dit
mais c'est avec les enveloppes les
enveloppes soins son interruption
partielle ou globalement il faut il faut
il faut peut-être se reposer la question
de l'intérêt des options globale qui
quand même sont mieux adaptés c'est en
fonctionnement de ce type là que
l'option partiel donc c'était un peu
technique mais c'est tous ces sujets là
tous ces sujets là sont sont là je crois
que c'est important et on a on a un
certain nombre de pistes se sont dans
nos 22 mesures là que j'ai pas eu le
temps de développer et je crois qu'il
faut maintenant les mettre en
application les renforcer et puis
peut-être tu termineras et sur un point
qui était le plus important c'est de
trouver les professionnels pour
appliquer ses propositions parce que
parler d attractivité des métiers
clairement ce secteur-là et un rapport
sur le sujet pour même elle comme ris et
c7 ces métiers sont difficiles pour
toute la chaîne de soins
il est urgent de se poser les questions
et de faire en sorte que ces métiers se
revaloriser sur tous les points y
compris sur l'image qui lui représente
pour être attractif cette capitale
auditionné les différentes fédérations
donc on a déjà travaillé sur les
personnes âgées mais l'art et la
question étaient précises qui aurait dû
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé et de maquis
douala tirer si jamais l'ondulation qui
remonte de façon qui aurait dû selon les
territoires et c est dans la dichotomie
entre le médico social et sanitaire vous
êtes plutôt a séparé les compétences
dans les établissements ou pas et puis
catherine des roches aura des questions
complémentaires on regarde cette
question est essentielle bon
il y en a un peu dans les concepts le
faire d'avoir séparé soit indépendance
déjà est un sujet nous qui nous bien sûr
qui nous interrogent parce que la
dépendance c'est finalement que la
conséquence de la maladie chronique dans
la majorité des cas il n'y a pas de
dépendance sans qu'il y ait une cause
médicale alors qu'on a pu ou non
identifié mais c'est la plupart du temps
les personnes âgées les personnes âgées
donc cette dichotomie déjà elle n'est
pas adaptée et ensuite effectivement on
voit que l'organisation territoriale
j'ai pas trop insisté il faut qu'on
revoie notre organisation sur les
définir les territoires de bons
territoire la bonne dimension et et
s'interroger sur les parcours des
personnes dans ce territoire et vérifier
que toute l'offre était présente pour
assurer sur un mode parcours les
réponses adaptées à ces populations
particulières parce que
polypathologiques présentant des
maladies aussi bien somatiques
neuropsychologiques donc des sujets
assez compliqué et pour lesquels les
réponses sont plurielles donc j'ai pas
beaucoup parlé de la coordination mais
il va falloir que nos dispositifs
d'appui à la coordination les femmes dac
soit véritablement efficient pour
remettre un peu d'ordre dans les
réponses parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
plutôt des réponses nombreuses pas
forcément coordonnées et les moyens sont
là mais sont pas bien utilisé donc il
faut revoir cette question et s'appuyer
sur un sujet qui m'est chère qui est le
plan personnalisé de santé qui définit
pour chaque individu ses besoins et au
regard desquels on doit mettre en place
les bonnes réponses
j'ai pas compris la question qu'est ce
qu'être d'armes tout le monde d'un petit
chalet territoire oui tout le monde la
tire mais finalement personne ne
l'entendez fois nous on a alors si
j'avais nous on a notre nos instances
quand même attire l'attention depuis
longtemps bien avant cette si celle-là
vous voulez mon nez je vais aisément
bien depuis bien longtemps bien avant la
crise vous avez value sur la canicule
je vais vous donner une information qui
en est un peu le témoin c'est ma
spécialité a été reconnu en 2004
c'est-à-dire un an après la canicule à
vos avant la gériatrie n'était pas une
spécialité donc ça c'est ça ça veut dire
des choses dont et donc on est une jeune
discipline je veux dire mon par ailleurs
nous ne cessons d'attirer l'attention
nous avons parlé du manifeste qui
comportait 15 mesures il en comporte
désormais 22 hier c'est notre façon à
nous de nous manifester bien avant la
crise donc tout ce que je vous ai dit
pratiquement aujourd'hui sont des
éléments qui étaient déjà dans nos dans
nos manifeste précédent peut-être qu'on
n'a pas su les faire connaître ça c'est
un autre sujet mais on a on a conscience
des connaît les sujets précisément et on
a un certain nombre de réponses
et voilà pour cette audition sur la
prise en charge des personnes âgées
pendant la crise sanitaire
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous donne rendez vous
demain pour des auditions très
importante de la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur la gestion de la crise du
cornet à virus avec à 10h30 l'audition
du président du conseil scientifique
jean françois delfraissy et à 15 heures
ne manquez pas l'audition du professeur
didier raoult l'edt devant la commission
denquête à suivre en direct sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr et sur
notre page facebook
très bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]
mais
mon